foreign
Frontiers introduces a new take on the
action adventure and platforming genres
by combining blistering speed with
blazing combat
for the first time Sonic has a skill
tree full of exciting and Powerful new
abilities to learn
to unlock new skills you'll need to
collect enough skill pieces from Fallen
enemies and breakable items around the
islands
Sonic also has a standard move set
including a homing attack
drop Dash
and stop at the beginning of the game
while these moves are effective against
normal enemies you'll need to level up
and unlock new skills if you want to
take on bigger and stronger foes
awaiting you on the Starfall Islands
a normal enemy on Kronos island is
nothing compared to those on later
Islands so make sure you're collecting
the red seeds of power and blue seeds of
Defense to boost your stats and give
yourself a Fighting Chance
as the game progresses and Sonic levels
up so do your enemies
completing combos is a good way to get
the upper hand during battle especially
when paired with a new skill called
Phantom Rush Sonic's combo meter will
fill up after attacking enemies
consecutively
once the combo meter is maxed out
Phantom Rush is activated and your
attack power will be boosted until the
meter reaches zero
to deal massive amounts of damage in a
short burst use Sonic Boom a long range
high-speed kick that unleashes shock
waves at the enemy
another option to dish out major hurt on
your enemies is wild Rush a flashy
zigzagging attack that sends you
crashing into your targets with great
force
it's a fast and stylish way to hit your
enemies hard while avoiding incoming
fire
certain enemies in Sonic Frontiers have
a shield or barrier protecting them
break their shield with silu and then
deal as much damage as you can before it
goes back up
if your opponent happens to land a hit
on you just use the siloop Ability on
the ground to collect more rings and get
back in the fight
during combat you'll need to study your
opponents and determine the best
strategy to take them on
encounters with guardians will require
more than just using your homing attack
many of them prompt you to engage with
their unique combat mechanics first
before reaching their weak spot once you
have an opening you can dish out all the
skills you've unlocked from the skill
tree
experimenting with new abilities and
discovering each enemy's weakness will
help you defeat them with ease
who's your enemies moves against them by
utilizing Perry during combat
a visual cue lets you know when an enemy
is about to attack if you react quickly
enough you can Parry it and follow it up
with a counter-attack of your own using
all these skills and more gives you tons
of options to become the most formidable
force in the frontier
master your approach to battle and teach
your enemies not to mess with Sonic the
Hedgehog
[Music]